Oh, this is going to be good. I love when Hutch like denies reality
entirely. I think it's happening because it happened, you know,
like I just can't believe the voters of Maine elected Grant Plathner.
I can't believe these Mainers are pushing such a harmful candidate.
How do people still operate with this guy when he says the dumbest
Apparently Hutch is snarking on Plathner. Give me a second. What
is
>> Here we go again, y'all. Here we go again. So, we have
another scandal involving Grant Plathner.
A bunch of people are working overtime desperately trying to
take this man down. So, take a look at this. Maine Democratic
Senate Senate frontrunner Grant Plathner engulfed in sex scandal
after wife alerts campaign to explicit messages with up to six
women. Okay. So, the claim here is that Grant was caught
about six different women.
I'm going to give you some specifics in a second. We have his
wife came out and addressed this. He has also come out and addressed
this. But, let me show you this. So, the person who got this
information
okay? They were told this in confidence
by the wife. The wife went to one of the staffers and said, "Hey,
is this going to hurt Grant?" Cuz like I hope it doesn't and
I >> Is Hutch commenting or watching? >> don't want
it to, but there was some infidelity and there were there was
sex >> How come some people are saying six and some people
are saying seven? What is with that discrepancy? >> It's
dead. It's dead. It's dead. Stop. >> The 12 or up to a
dozen figure comes from Jennifer McDonald, the former campaign
aide
who was the source for the story. McDonald said that Gertner
told her that her husband had been exchanging messages with as
many as a dozen women. This is McDonald relaying what she says
Plathner's wife, Amy Gertner, told her during the campaign's
internal vetting last summer. The six figure comes from the Plathner
campaign itself. A campaign official told The Times that Plathner
had been communicating with up to six women. And aides concluded
when they learned of it that it was a private matter the couple
had addressed in
so it's important to note here that so she was the source for
the New York Times. She went on the record with the New York
Times, but she only went on the record with the New York Times
after this guy, Morris Katz, who's like this
>> You're saying this
and yet she was the person who this was shared with. So Hutch
is going to go with the story of, well, it was only shared with
one person, only one person knew. But somehow when that story
went to the Times, they had a different third-party source, like
a different source entirely.
Even though there's only one person who was told. How?
How? How?
Like what are we Are we just not using We're not engaging our
brains at all?
>> He's like a six-year-old running Platter's campaign,
I think. I think he's like a DSA guy. Um, he threatened Jenifer
McDonald
and told her to, you know, call the Wall Street Journal and deny
the claims. He basically told her to lie to the Wall
>> No, he I think he said it was a lie and if they went
through with it, they were going to expose her for being the
person who propagated the lie.
>> Journal, according to her.
Otherwise, he would throw her under the bus even though she claimed
she was not the source for the Wall Street Journal story. And
it was after Morris Katz threatened Jenifer McDonald that she
went to the New York Times like a queen, by the way, and went
on the record. Um so there's that. >> Why is she like a
queen? Why would that be like a queen to
Is Hutch even paying Hutch Hutch Hutch Hutch Hutch?
She's just trying to sculp a Democratic candidate. What do you
mean like a queen, you f-
She was a campaign manager. She was somebody who was on this
campaign and only received this information as a part of opposition
research. She is a Democratic operative using Democrat Oppo research
for her own candidate, trying to help her own candidate. She's
using that to undermine his campaign after he's become the presumed
nominee in Maine. Are you out of your
This absolute queen.
Are you a
Are you an actual I just can't understand why you'd be psyched
about this. What Why would you be psyched about this? This is
insane. It's not even some like Like it's not some underlying
hidden
It's not some underlying like hidden thing that shows he lied
about his campaign or lied about some policy positions or that
he's lying to anyone. It's Hey, this guy was on like Kick or
something. And by the way, we still don't know what the nature
of the messages are. Have Have these messages even been surfaced
yet? I don't know what they >> says, "It's no one's business
what happened in Graham and Amy's marriage before he was ever
candidate for office. There should be no place in our politics
for incompetent opportunistic operatives who violate privacy,
betray trust, and prioritize vengeance over decency." Rebecca
Katz says, "Also, a really special place in hell for the kind
of staffer who says to the candidate's wife, 'You can trust me.'
and then turns around and tells the world." In fact, look at
this. >> Is Hutch going to Hutch is going to do the thing
where he pretends he can't hear, right? Hutch is going to do
the
thing where he doesn't respond, he doesn't say anything. He is
just going to ignore the actual facts cuz he is a [__]
loser. Is that what we're going to have here? Is that what we're
watching? He's going to ignore what happened so that he doesn't
have to deal with the fact that this person is not someone you
should ever support.
>> What's the benefit of tearing Graham tearing down Graham?
I don't even like that framing, man. I think he's I think that
campaign and him are tearing himself down.
Um you know, I think he's probably going to lose to Collins.
That's what I think. >> Think that campaign is tearing
itself
Dude, how
How do people still operate with this guy when he says the dumbest
things?
Like how do people honestly network with this person when he
is so clearly
stupid? Like embarrassingly
stupid to the point that it like it it betrays belief, it belies
belief. I I can't believe it. I am dumbfounded listening to this
guy speak.
When they're betrayed by a campaign aid, when that campaign aid
explicitly endeavors to undermine their campaign after being
the person running it,
That's them up. What you should be saying is this person, Genevieve
McDonald, should never operate in politics ever again.
They have betrayed the Democratic Party. They should no longer
be welcome in Democratic politics.
That's what you should be saying.
Regardless of what they leak, they should not be Unless they
have something substantial, right? Something that isn't just
uh that that isn't infidelity, that isn't something they were
trying to keep private, right?
If they've got substantial stuff showing he's lying about policy
positions, or even that he used to that he lied about the Nazi
tattoo, which they tried to paint this story as if he was lying
about it, by the way. A lot of people did on Twitter, very interesting.
Oh, unless you have something like that, you are out of Democratic
politics. It's not at all self-destruction when somebody is betraying
you. Come on, man. >> Hutch, that staffer, the one who
talked to the Times, is probably never getting hired in politics
again. No campaign will trust her with anything sensitive. Um
I I don't know enough about that person's backstory. Maybe she's
got like a sterling reputation or whatever. I I really have no
idea.
>> What is the So, think about it. Or look into it. Why
wouldn't you just think about it? If if the wife of the candidate
goes to and says, "Hey, I I'm concerned these could be these
could come up in the campaign." And then she says, "Don't worry
about it. That's between you guys. Don't worry about it. We're
not going to disclose that cuz it would be bad to disclose it
and it's like private and it's not anybody else's business."
And then she takes those same messages and leaks them to the
press. In what universe should that person ever be hired again,
Hutch? What? >> But I mean it it it does seem like kind
of a big deal to be leaking that kind of
thing, you know. And a former staffer decided, "Let me try to
take down Platner by releasing this information anyway, betraying
the trust." Not what happened. Not what happened. Unsurprisingly,
Kyle Kulinski is incorrectly describing the sequence of events.
It's so out of character for
Please go with the actual sequence of
>> He get basic facts about stories wrong. He's usually
so rigorous and careful. >> of Platter Unless you just
believe when they say, "Well, this The only person who knew about
it, who told us not to bring it up with anyone else, that they
basically came out and said, 'Well, no, no, no, no, I didn't
leak any of that stuff.'" Unless you believe that, I don't I
don't
>> And I'm supposed to say I'm done with Platter cuz he
had consensual affairs years ago? I'm supposed to say that's
a red line and now I can't support the guy?
>> Cuz he had consensual affairs years ago. Oh my god.
>> Oh, this is going to be good. I love when Hutch like
denies reality entirely.
Right? I love when Hutch denies like that is just a factual statement.
He's not saying his wife consented to the affairs. He's saying
he didn't anybody. And obviously, when you've got a president
the bar is a little bit lower than you'd expect. Right? >> I
don't know, man. Maybe Maybe I'm too vanilla. Maybe I'm Maybe
I got >> What do you mean? What do you mean too
We don't even KNOW WHAT GRANDPA PLATTER was talking about. What
do you mean too vanilla? You're not too vanilla. >> got
too boring as I as I grew older, but >> He's trying to
make it about sex weirdly. It's not about sex. It's about trust.
It's about he was deceptive to his wife and that is a mark against
him if it's true, but I don't know what their dynamic is. It
could be, and here's just me spitballing a little bit, it could
be that they actually agreed to this and this dynamic wasn't
that big an issue. And when the wife took these sex to somebody,
she could have said like, "Well, this is like a whole thing.
I just want to make sure that this couldn't be used against us,
right?" Maybe they had a whole thing. I don't know. I kind of
doubt it. But I don't know. If that were the case,
they probably don't want to make it public. Right?
They have some some like genuine like, "Oh, we actually get off
on the infidelity element, but we just do it through role-play
over text." If there's something like that, they would never
ever ever want to reveal that publicly. It would just be weird.
You know what I'm saying? Like But I I don't even necessarily
think that's true. I'm just saying that clearly when they don't
want to comment on it cuz they don't want it under public scrutiny,
I'm okay with that. If there was somebody else at risk of harm,
maybe you have a different conversation. But there is not anyone
else at risk of harm here. >> Someone is
anywhere between a half dozen to a dozen
as a newlywed.
That to me implies a level of
that does make me question
ability to serve as a senator without becoming a distraction.
>> Don't hedge. Don't hedge on this. You're right. Oh,
I'm not hedging. Um that's just that's extreme
>> That's very possible, Hutch. Unfortunately now, that's
your candidate.
That's your candidate, bro.
So I'm ready to tell you that's your
I'm hoping that Hutch understands that a distraction in the Senate
while having Senate majority is more important than not having
the distraction there and losing two more Supreme Court seats,
We get that I I don't know if Hutch realizes that. But like I'll
take an impulsive person in this case. No?
I can't see why not. >> Dream impulsivity.
Extreme impulsivity. Some people will try to accuse me of hypocrisy
because like, oh, it's funny you have this opinion of Platner,
but you have nothing to say about Destiny. It's like, well, first
of all, I do have things to say about Destiny. I think he is
I think he himself has come out and said that he's been quite
impulsive in that kind of way and it's caused him
>> How was he impulsive, Hutch? Go ahead.
Could Hutch say how he was impulsive,
Does Hutch want to say it? No, no, Hutch Hutch doesn't want to
say it. Wait till Hutch learns about Colin's escapades.
Like Colin's who was had a long-term affair with a dude before
he left his dying wife, his wife with cancer. Man, I don't want
to I don't even want to say it cuz Hutch should know how important
support systems are when somebody is sick, right?
But Susan Collins' husband left his wife with cancer to marry
Susan Collins.
So cool, man. >> If Destiny was running for Senate
in Maine,
I would I would be pissed at Destiny. >> Would you be talking
consistently in a way that like denigrates it that like lowers
his chance of winning? I would I wouldn't cover it personally.
If Destiny was running for Senate in Maine, I would stop covering
it cuz I wouldn't be able to hold my tongue. I'd just be like,
"No, no, no, I'm not talking about it."
That's like the bare minimum.
>> about this because it's a it's like with our chances
like with a winnable seat. It's like becoming a distraction.
And it would it would piss me off. >> You're helping it
turn into a distraction because you haven't even seen the text.
You don't know what the dynamic was.
You actually don't.
You are letting it turn into You are trying to help, actually,
turn it into a
Because you would rather this guy lose, you would rather he go
down in flames than the Democrats get a majority in the Just
say that. Just be honest about it, man. Come on. >> But
it is extremely impulsive
maybe compulsive behavior that would would make me question someone's
ability to serve efficiently as a
And I think like that reaction is, you
>> Okay. I Listen, this is a great conversation to have
with somebody who's not the presumed nominee already.
Fantastic conversation, right? I It doesn't have to go to anybody
else. I don't care. I think Hutch's ability to perceive information
changes massively on the Grand Platinum versus Destiny thing.
He's showed that very obviously, right? That he will just regularly
shut down and not take in information that cuts against his biases.
But, that's whatever. It is what it is, okay? For Hutch here,
it that doesn't matter. You should just be blue no matter who.
You should be looking for a way to make this like not a big deal.
And unfortunately for Hutch, he's also not like waiting for information.
He's just going to continuously talk about how this guy "Well,
I just question this guy's judgment. I just don't know if I could
vote for this. I just don't know if I could tell people to vote
for this guy cuz like I kind of question his judgment." Do you
question a Republican majority's judgment when it comes to nominating
Supreme Court justices?
I would hope so. I would hope you'd question their judgment in
that
more than you question Grain Platner a bunch of women on whatever
app, okay?
>> So much time is going to be spent
addressing this guy's character flaws and mistakes.
>> Not true. Not true at all.
And again, foundationally,
far more egregious character flaws are excused in politicians
all the time.
Look at people trying to take, you know, what's what was her
name? Oh, why am I I'm blanking on her name. Is it No, it's not
Virginia governor. It's not Spanberger. It's um Slotkin. The
Slotkin person, right?
She's sitting there getting mad at Crystal Ball for questioning
her on
When she says, "I get all the military reports. I know exactly
what's going on there. I don't think like I don't lose sleep
over it."
Right? That is an inherently far worse moral person. Like mor-
morally, that person is far worse than whatever Grain Platner's
done somebody. Yeah?
Yeah, I've got the sand I've got some of the Sanders quotes from
today as well. Dude, Bernie nails it though. Actually, I wasn't
going to pull this up right now. Bernie nails it perfectly. Bernie
just slam dunks it. Look here, 30 seconds. This is all you needed
this whole time was just this response from
Midas Touch pulling this up. I guarantee you every Midas Touch
will be saying the same thing. It's so easy.
What impresses me about what's going on in Maine is and you may
or may not know is that Republican super PACs are and then he
continues.
Graham Platter is having a massive campaign run against him because
he will stand up for working people. Is he a saint? I guess not.
But I ain't know too many saints in that in that house of Congress,
okay? In that chamber, I ain't know too many saints. So I'm riding
with my boy Graham.
How easy is it?
How easy is it? How? It's so
It's so easy, dude. It's so easy. God, it's just so simple.
Destiny has more experience in his pinky toe than anyone in there,
especially
>> Guys, why do people call me an orbiter? I don't even
understand it, man.
Okay, hold on. I I do I do Listen, as much as that guy said something
up here, I've got to give it up that he actually does have the
situation seen otherwise, okay? That as much as I want to [__]
on that guy,
he says that, but then he says this won't matter in a week. Clock
it, folks. It is just an attack. It's like clearly being paid
for.
I would say not even paid for. It's clearly being astroturfed,
right? >> And it's just a drag. >> Nobody will care
about it in a week. Just don't be a [__]
Just chill, man.
>> it's just a drag on the whole party and
yeah, that bothers me.
weak is your party, man? The Republicans, you want to talk about
a drag on a on a party, Donald Trump won an election while saying
that a former war hero who ran for president and did well with
Republicans was a loser because he got captured and tortured
in
You want to talk about an anchor on a
how weak is your party that you can't carry Grant Plathner possibly
having some kind of infidelity with his wife? We don't even know
for sure yet exactly like how bad it is or what it is.
But how can you say that Grant Plathner is an anchor when the
Republicans carried Donald Trump over the finish line and he
became an asset?
I'm not even saying you let this go or say it's okay. I I don't
You don't have to say it's okay. Cheating is wrong. Lying is
bad.
But I don't even know the nature yet and you're like dumping
this guy and saying, "Oh, it's too much of a distraction." Guess
what? If you haven't been paying attention,
distractions are called earned media.
media. Grant Plathner is earning media. And so, while I think
you could say, you know, on a personal level seems like he's
kind of untrustworthy, I think you should look at his policy,
look at his platform, and decide whether or not that's a candidate
you want in the Senate. Understanding that on the other side,
guess what? Susan Collins don't give a [__] about
fidelity or the truth, either.
Ultimately, that doesn't matter. Listen to the rhetoric, listen
to the policy prescriptions, and decide which person is better.
Cuz Susan Collins ain't no saint, either, okay? As Bernie alluded
to, don't know too many saints in that chamber over there.
>> Pisses me off. Cheating on your spouse is a moral failing.
Why would you want politicians whose morals are so that they
aren't even faithful?
>> You don't want them. You just don't have another option.
I wish you had another option. Maybe this would have been good
if this came out earlier, right? I think part of the part of
the calculation here has to be the timing, yeah?
Now, could Hutch use his his tiny little itty-bitty brain and
think, why didn't this get leaked until it was too late for Dems
to replace Platner? Well, if you think about it, who would want
to release this after Grant Platner was locked in as the candidate?
Well,
if they released it earlier, it could have helped it could have
helped Janet Mills, right? And now it like doesn't help Janet
Mills at all. And now it's like Grant Platner's basically the
presumptive nominee and well, huh, so who does this benefit?
Well,
no, Queen Queen leaked that stuff on Grant Platner, honey.
You literally said that. Like a queen, she leaked it to the New
York Times. Like a queen, she went on the record with the New
York Times.
You're a loser, man. You don't stand for anything. You're an
embarrassment.
>> to the one that they chose to marry. You know, like
I'm not going to say that infidelity
is a lot by itself disqualifying. It's disappointing behavior.
It's hurtful behavior.
But alone like that alone is not disqualifying for me. What makes
the
problematic for me is the she like the number of women that he
was number one, that's a lot. Like
six to 12 women, that's a lot to be with, you know, within two
years of being married.
Um so that's like that makes me furrow my eyebrows a little bit.
The story wouldn't have been as big. I don't even think I would
have had a strong reaction
if it was just one person that he was having an affair with and
he took ownership of the affair and didn't victimize himself.
Like that to me wouldn't be disqualifying. It's not great behavior,
but >> What is this Destiny Orbiter saying?
Basically, he's pretending that Grant
breaking his wedding vows is like a deal breaker for him because
he sexted
He says 6 to 12 women. I've not seen the 12 number. Where is
that coming from? I've no idea.
>> Infidelity is you know, shockingly common in marriages
and so I just
I don't judge couples for working through infidelity and staying
together and and you know, I just don't make it a habit of like
judging people on that spot. Um, but six to 12 women and then
spinning the story as though you're a
They're just coming after me because I'm you know, I a draw a
heart. >> The significant is that it was within two years
of his marriage, unforgivable.
I don't get to decide what's forgivable. I wouldn't forgive somebody.
I I would feel like totally betrayed in that situation. I don't
get to say I don't get to say what's unforgivable for another
couple, right? I don't know the situation.
That's the biggest thing is yes, cheating with 12 people in the
first year of your relationship or first two years would be unforgivable
to me, but I don't know that it was cheating for one
I don't know what the sex were. I don't know what the like is
this guy
Is this guy going to some anonymous
to like sex with women cuz he like gets off on doing this little
story time thing and he doesn't think of it as cheating and it's
like an idiosyncrasy that his wife thinks is cheating and they
talk about it and he says, I didn't even realize this could be
really that bad. I've been doing it for a long time and I'll
stop because it it bothers you and I I didn't think of it that
way. I thought of it like watching Like what if that's the case,
right? What if he used to just do this all the time and what
he does instead of watching porn or
Well, it was anonymous messaging apps,
Now, I don't believe that. I wouldn't I wouldn't believe somebody
if they told me that. But, what if he said that and he changed
it and they worked through it and they were fine?
Is that my place to say that's like
out of
Is that like totally insane?
Oh, it's exaggerated. Okay, I got it. I >> couples for
working through infidelity and staying together and and, you
know, I just don't make it a habit of like judging people on
that spot. Um but >> six to 12 women and then spinning
the story as though you're a victim.
They're just coming at >> Yeah, Hutch. You You hate it
when people spin the stories if they're the victim,
Okay, Hutch.
He really hates that. That concept is gross. THAT'S THAT'S DISGUSTING.
YEAH, HUH. YEAH, HUH. >> after me because I'm, you know,
I had draw a hard line on Israel. It just drives me insane.
Like, where is the accountability? Where is the responsibility?
Um >> I would assume that's taken to the person harmed,
which is his wife.
It doesn't sound like this was new information to her,
Where's the accountability? Where's the responsibility? Does
he owe that accountability or responsibility to the public? Or
does he owe it to his wife? Was he lying to some Like, is is
there even a harm other than the wife?
Like, I If he was dodging accountability or responsibility to
somebody he'd hurt, I could understand this. But, there's nothing
here.
Like, there's nothing here that says we deserve to be like a
part of this.
>> He was recruited by the DSA. I don't think that's true.
Was he? I don't know if that's true. I know he was recruited,
but I don't know if it was from the DSA. Was it?
>> Didn't Hutch say that earlier? I thought Hutch literally
already said that. >> my individual taxes. That money right
there isn't going to pay for all the things that you want. Sure,
Jeff. That's right. That's why we're not raising it just on you.
We're raising it on all 930
billionaires in the United States. It's why we're also not just
going after your income, but I think we have to go after the
wealth as well. The wealth that they sit on, the wealth that
they never actually bring into the real world so they don't have
to pay capital gains on it, but they borrow against it happily
so they can have liquidity to go through their lives.
Of course Jeff Bezos is going to tell us that if we raise his
taxes, things won't get better. He doesn't want us to raise his
taxes. He's a greedy person. I mean, that makes perfect sense
to me that he would say that. He's just uh entirely wrong and
self-serving. >> They will try anything and everything.
They will destroy you before they will allow you get some power
to raise their taxes and give people health care and give people
education and end the wars.
They just They just won't allow it. They don't want it, okay?
And that's why this is happening. And by the way >> I I
think it's happening because it happened, you know, like
I think it's happening because it
I I'm sorry. This guy just doesn't understand that the way stuff
gets sort of messaged, the way stuff gets reacted to, that has
to do with his positions.
That there would be people backing him if this Trust me. There'd
be people looking to kill the story if he had certain positions.
He is getting none of the advantages you would get as an establishment
candidate.
I just can pretend that doesn't exist, but it's the exact kind
of rap that basically keeps the establishment the the establishment.
I It's just It's very obvious. It's not even like something crazy
that Kyle's saying. >> The story is a story because it
You know, he did sext like many, many women outside of his >> You
said 12.
dude, even the infidelity element I think is like up in the air
right now.
Like I She didn't say infidelity in her video
But I I actually maybe she did say it in a response to some of
the articles. I'm trying to figure out what I should go back
and like actually analyze the language like a lawyer and see
exactly what they're saying cuz I think they almost knock it
down into one specific bucket. If you go and like re- re-listen
to specifically, like if if you think of them as lawyers trying
to say a very specific thing without saying it, I think they
sort of narrow it down. >> marriage. When she was doing
IVF treatments for infertility and he did have a still active
Kik account.
KIK. Like
what pisses me off the most about Plotkin is not even his moral
failings. It's like he genuinely seems like a [__]
That's crazy. They found his old Reddit account with the same
username, by the way, P Hustle, which is just pretty hilarious.
Like it's like something straight out of The Office. >> Wait,
are the messages even from Kik? Or did that just come out at
the same time? Wait, what if he like wasn't really using the
Kik account? Have we heard if the messages were from Kik or Do we
know? >> They found his old Reddit account and he didn't
think to delete that Kik account. He was like, "Oh, you know,
probably fine. Nobody will find it." >> Uh
there's something to that like not deleting it right away.
Like you don't want to give people the impression that you're
moving the body. If you run away from stuff like that, if you
just delete,
how does the story change tangibly if somebody's already saved
that
See, this is this is the kind of stupid [__] that
I'm talking about. This is the total failing a total failing
in terms of addressing the second-order concern. Okay, I have
a Kik account. I just deactivate it immediately.
Have you thought about what happens if you immediately deactivate
that Kik account? Have you thought about how that
If you immediately deactivate that Kik account when something
else bad happens. When you go, you do an interview and you say
there's no more skeletons in my
And then you go and delete that Kik account like immediately.
How does that look to people?
Right? You do have to think a little bit further and you have
to understand, I assume somebody got it to him at got it through
his head at some point. Anything you've had online,
that's found already. That's found and somebody's just waiting
to expose this. Anything you've ever done, it's all found and
somebody's just waiting to put it out there in the public to
try to paint a narrative against you,
I hope he Grant Platner better understand that or he's a [__]
I just think it's funny that Hutch is like, "No, no, no, you
should you should just go delete that immediately."
And then Grant Platner tries to hide secret account from the
public. >> See, like why did you not delete that immediately?
You know, it's not even the Nazi tattoo, it's not even the infidelity,
it's just he seems like a genuine [__] >> Oh,
I don't know if Jacob's still watching. We will get to the Lego
stuff after this if we keep going. That's where we'll go. We'll
do Lego >> thing is frustrating because, you know,
my like I've long felt that, you know,
the corner of Democratic Party politics that Kyle Kulinski and
and his colleagues [clears throat] um occupy
are so convinced that the Democratic Party needs to run their
preferred candidates all over the country, and the only reason
why the Democratic Party has lost in the modern era to Republicans
is because, you know, they don't listen to people like Kyle.
And yet people like Kyle push these bad candidates that just
have these obvious problems. And so it's it's just it's so
So unbelievable.
>> I just want to be clear that Grant Platner, regardless
of whether or not Kyle Kulinski pushed him,
was winning the Maine primary.
Does this idiot not realize that I just can't believe the voters
of Maine elected Grant Platner. I can't believe these Maine are
pushing such a HARMFUL CANDIDATE. HOW DARE THEY? How dare they
do this? Maine voters, man. Cuz that's who ultimately put Graham
Platner on the map? Right?
It wasn't Cenk Uygur, it wasn't Hasan [__] it wasn't
even Bernie Sanders, it was Graham Platner. Well, maybe it was
Bernie Sanders a lot, but if anybody put him on the map, it was
Bernie.
And the main voters who are getting pulled are the ones who said
they wanted him. So much so that Janet Mills just dropped out.
She just killed her campaign. She was like, "Oh, this is a total
waste. Shouldn't even try." That's the problem is that the main
voters like this guy.
And unfortunately again for Hodge, there's so few people in Maine
that it's conceivable Graham Platner might actually get to talk
to almost all of them. They might all see him in
Like realistically, you might see every voting of age adults,
okay? Every voting adult in Maine may see their view with their
physical eyes, their actual eyeballs. That's what you're fighting
against, and it's going to be difficult to convince people that
he's bad. >> Now, people like Kyle are forced to double
down over and over and over and
with each new story that drops. And apparently, there's a really
bad story that's about to drop soon about assault. And you know,
we're now we're going to be in you know, firmly in Donald Trump
MAGA territory cuz if if sexual if if the if the rumors are true
that there's a story coming out about him doing assault in college
and there are multiple women that are coming forward in this
story.
Well, I listen.
I don't know. Is is Hodge just like one of the Republicans' most
powerful operators? Why is it Can I Can I just ask Does he not
think about the timing here? Does he not think about how he's
being used in some way? Or maybe he's just relishing it. Maybe
he's like actually psyched about this because this looks bad
for the left wing of the party if if this all comes out right
and he he gives credence to it. Do you see the timing? Like how
the timing is lining up? Like that was a reason that you could
be skeptical of the Eric Swalwell stuff because of the timing
at which it was like with which it was coming out. Now, I think
for Swalwell, he [__] up one of his aides, right?
If Swalwell hadn't [__] one of his aides and it was
just rumors of sexual assault or something, maybe
maybe it was like
that could be bad, maybe. But I don't think he instantly drops
out.
But with the actual story from a former aide that he had that
he was like getting up from on the way to a campaign event. She
was What was she like 20? She was young, right? What was she
like 19, 20, 21?
That was like, okay, that's yeah, stop the presses. Stop it now.
Okay, this guy is he's using his power for bad. We we're not
going to let this guy No, no, no, no, no. Come on, man. But there's
nothing I I can't imagine there's going to be something like
that with Plaitner, but we'll see. I Where are we seeing the
whole thing about sexual assault? I'm guessing Hutch is What's
he going to >> do? Is he really going to double down then?
And at that point, how are you any different from like the Republican
conservative media pundits that double down on Trump
after, you know,
>> Wouldn't you just say you want to see
Don't you Why Why would you not want to see evidence? But if
there is actual real evidence that this guy assaulted somebody
in college, it should be bad for him. It should actually possibly
sewer his campaign, right? Depending on what it is. But you have
to actually evaluate the evidence. You shouldn't just say, "Well,
actually if anybody accuses this guy of sexual assault now, I
have to disavow him." That's stupid, man. >> Who dozen
women came out with sexual assault allegations?
That the whole thing is like so disappointing on a number of
levels, you
>> I still don't see I'm looking for anything to do with
sexual assault and Grant Plaitner. All I see is stuff about the
Reddit
I the way, guys,
what's going around now, allegedly,
a hell of people are talking about it on the on Twitter. Have
you guys heard of the new allegations that are Dude, hell of
people be talking about it. Hell of peeps be talking about it.
This guy is such a Do you want to know who?
Adam Platner is great, okay? Hutch is a total slave. There is
no better usage of slave than for Hutch. This guy is the most
useful idiot.
Well, I read it on Twitter and it's like totally it seems like
kind of, you know, hell of people talk about it, man.
Cool. Grand Platner is going to have a very long day tomorrow.
Oh, that was today. Well, what came out
There's no way it's just this tweet, right? NRSC Communications
Director.
Senate Republicans, the NRSC is dedicated to protecting our Republican
Senate majority.
So, Hutch is specifically going to the Communications Director
for protecting the Senate majority, the NRSC, I National Republican
Senate Committee, Senate something. And Hutch is just like, "Well,
I'm going to start talking about whatever they say. I'm going
to I'm going to I'm going to take what they say and I'm just
going to run with it. I'm just going to run with it."
Anyway, I guess we don't have anything coming out and Hutch is
just going to take the Communications Director for protecting
the Republican majority at her word and start running with it.
Very cool, Hutch.
That's very awesome.